Mike I enjoyed watching your I think
believe it was 2010-2011 like this photo
collage of all the people and the food
and the animals and the kids and
everyone that you'd met along the road
for the time when you traveled and you
did things and went to different events
what's your philosophy on life travel
and filmmaking it seems like people
gravitate towards you easily you seem to
have these friendships that you keep for
very long time yeah ya are I make these
picture videos where I just take the you
know fifty thousand photos i shot that
year and pull them all into this a video
I need to make one for 2012-13 but yeah
I mean those years were crazy I I
definitely travels to a lot of different
places two thousand nine ten eleven i
was i was traveling and traveling all
around so i guess you know you just take
your camera with you and you kind of
document your your experience and that's
kind of what i've done is i've gotten
into photography as well and just sort
of shoot and it's just fun and you just
interact with a lot of different people
so i guess you know if i had to
summarize a philosophy it's just you
know be nice and and i think with that
I've been able to meet a lot of people
and go a lot of different places and do
some amazing projects so let's say
you're somewhere new and you want to
pull out the camera and start shooting
do you ask first you know especially in
LA people get so funny but I'm sure
other parts the country it's different
yeah I mean you're all you're always you
know if it's a proper shoot then people
know you're shooting if it's with
friends or family then sometimes you
know I'm taking pictures for people and
they want you know great you know Mike's
here let's get some free photos or
whatever so it's been really enjoyable
just to be kind of that person that has
the expertise to know you know how to
shoot the photos so
you